everyone depends on hospitals roads
police and schools but they're expensive
and governments across the world are
feeling the pinch
so how can we continue in the future to
afford good quality public services why
has pressure on public services
increased
populations are aging
as the number of retirees grows
working people are going to have to pay
more taxes to support
them and as healthcare technology
improves the cost of healthcare is also
going to rise
but where to find the cash
basically governments can tax three
things income consumption or wealth
it's not your imagination income taxes
really have been increasing over the
past 50 years
the evidence shows that taxes on income
including corporation tax discourage
people from working
countries with low income taxes such as
the uk
tend to have stronger economic growth
second consumption
this is things like sales tax in america
or value-added tax on purchases in
europe
one problem with consumption taxes is
that they hit poorer people hardest who
spend more of their income on day-to-day
expenses third we have wealth taxes this
could be a better idea than taxing
income or consumption this is partly
because it places a higher levy on the
things that rich people have such as
property
and investments
some economists advocate something
called a land value tax and this is
basically where you tax the value of
plots of land and this could raise a lot
of money
a land value tax has very few
unintentional bad consequences
the problem is that taxing wealth is not
politically easy
homeowners for instance are going to be
furious if they're asked to pay higher
property taxes but if people want good
government services it's going to need
money
taxes on wealth are always unpopular but
sooner or later governments are going to
have to bite
you